The traveling salesman problem falls
into a special class of problems called
NP-Hard.
NP-Hard problems don't have a known
algorithm that can solve them
in polynomial time.
As I mentioned during the discussion of
the Knapsack Problem, polynomial time
algorithms have a run time where n has
a constant exponent like n squared and
we want algorithms that can solve
problems in polynomial time or
they're often too slow to be useful.
The Knapsack problem is actually
also an NP-Hard problem.
The solution we looked at was
in Pseudo-Polynomial time and
no true polynomial
time solution is known.
Since the problem is so
difficult, there are two classes of
algorithms considered solutions.
The first are exact algorithms, which
don't happen in polynomial time but
will get us the correct answer.
The second are Approximation Algorithms,
which don't always find the exact
optimal solution but
generally find a near optimal solution.
They tend to run in a more
reasonable amount of time, and
several are even polynomial time.
The Brute Force solution to TSP has the
same philosophy as the one for Knapsack.
Find every possible combination and
pick the best one, but
it takes significantly longer.
It's in factorial time, so n multiplied
by every integer between it and one.
There are also dynamic
programming solutions for TSP.
The most famous one is
the Held-Karp Algorithm.
However, even the dynamic
programming solutions are slow.
The runtime for this particular
solution is an exponential time.
Even though the approximation algorithms
don't find the exact optimal path,
there is a lot of active
research into them for TSP.
One of the most famous, called
Christofides algorithm, works by turning
a graph into a tree, where the starting
note is the root creating and
traversing through it in
a particularly intelligent way.
The algorithm guarantees
that the path it produces
will be at most 50% longer
than the shortest route.
There have been some slight improvements
on this first specific cases of TSP but
generally it's considered
to be the best there is.
TSP is an interesting case study for
this type of difficult problem,
particularly, since it has so many
applications and is so widely studied.
While you likely won't get asked
about it directly in an interview,
it's good to know that
problems like this exist and
that it is possible to get an interview
problem with no efficient solution.
You don't need to worry too much
about the exact meaning of NP-Hard or
similar classes, but
it's good to remember that
even the brightest minds can't
solve every problem efficiently.